any advice on screen writing books
what's the best screenwriting book
you've read
I think Sid fields is still probably the
Bible as a first one I ever read I write
every day still this day I find writing
probably I find writing very enjoyable
although it's hellacious at the same
time because I know that's the only part
of the process I know is solely me
everything else is pretty much
collaborative you know it's give and
take when you're writing you don't have
to give or take generally you know I
also take a long time well it's funny I
will think about a script for at least a
year or two before I ever commit
anything to paper because what I do
first is I know the story that I want to
tell and then I build out the characters
and I want to know I have to build out
the characters so well that they can
then end up just talking to each other
and then I can literally vomit out a
script in days generally how it works
for me and that I do rewrites from there
but also to is I only will create
characters of Doisneau play as an actor
you know I find that you know like my
next project is going to be a challenge
for my two leads in a big way and and
yeah and but that's kind of like why
like I love writing and the thing is -
it's like with writing it's all in a
rewrite and the biggest thing we're
writing to is like I like to share what
I what I'm writing with people and get
their honest feedback I don't do it -
people are gonna be yes you know say
like oh this is great like I literally
want real criticism and also - is
getting back to the whole entrepreneur
spirit of this stuff is I'm so bold that
I will hold live script readings of my
scripts for audience feedback the
audience literally pays to go I pay the
actors I generally make money all my
stress ratings and but at the same time
it's very valuable
because then I hear what's working
what's not working and also to us get
the audience feedback again all part of
this whole story are indeed that I've
been very much involved in and how I
create and I actually I have like four
stages of that I find that you need to
create to be successful and this doesn't
just go for film but it also goes for if
you're a musician or an artist you have
a dance company or whatever and so it's
matter of something that I've been
perfecting over the course of Billboard
and it's it's funny because you
mentioned the whole know film school
it's like literally what I wrote in new
films called the four stages of career
for a creative success and I blogged
about it and everything else as well but
writing is is the most crucial part of
this whole thing and if something's not
working on set that's also - it's
important that you actually sit down and
and kind of rewrite and make sure that
it will work I mean mind you as I said
before with Billboard is that when we
got into post it didn't some elements
just didn't work and so I had to rewrite
and and billboards very is a very very
complex script to write because not only
did I have to worry about the feature
film but I also had to worry about how
it fit into the web series so if I would
change one thing in the film and had to
make sure it worked for the webseries
it was very very complex and also to is
like how our plan with media is that
some some shots we shot we actually had
to do three different iterations of that
scene to get the entire scene for
instance like you know we would have a
news cast a newscaster speaking on TV
but on the screen and the newscast was
part of the Billboard contest and then
that screen ended up being in another
shot so you know like just what you had
to go through to try and make this whole
thing happen that was a big a big
challenge with with the scrapped
literally having to like realize that
one scene sometimes took you know three
different pieces of three different
layers I should say to make the the
scene cohesive well you said that you
you think about the idea for a film for
maybe one or two years and then
basically you vomit out the first draft
because you feel like you know the story
and the character so well do you give
that draft sometime before you go in for
the
right or do you no way actually I do I
generally give it a week or two and then
I'll reread it and then from right there
is when I start to make notes it's funny
because when I when people ask me to
read scripts I break out a pen and and I
will literally start I just I don't know
why but I literally if it's formatting
issue or anything like that
and quite honestly if like things are
not right in the first 10 pages I won't
carry on oh you won't know if I'm
engaged I'm gonna rewrite it it's it's
it you know you're formatting is off
this XY and Z and everything else you
know there's too many spelling mistakes
I mean it's crazy it's like it's like
it's like I know it sounds horrible but
if you're gonna if you're gonna ask me
to take my time to read something make
sure it's readable you know it's
important it's not just just
respectfully it's important I think you
know I've had people that like oh I've
got this great script you know they gave
me a title now okay sure I'll read it
and then it's not even in short format
it's like what the hell you do it you
know like look I can't even read this
and the people will understand
either's because screenwriting there is
a formula for it because you know as a
producer now like I know that a page is
gonna base to be a minute of a screen
time if it's a very black page it's
gonna be more than one minute
you know black beige meaning a lot of
action that's spelled out in the script
and so you know so I sort of thinking
about budget I start think about all
these sorts of things I'm reading a
script but whether I could produce it or
what I would need to do to be able to
make it happen and so my I'm always
reading something as a producer first
before I read it I guess that's why I'm
probably reading somebody script so for
me to produce it my own scripts those
I'm pretty I'm very tough on myself and
like I just write and rewrite and write
and rewrite and write and rewrite how do
you know when it's done
it's not done to them editing because
you still added things in you know you
still head of things show you're
constantly editing the eye location
you're editing generally you because you
might not you know use a certain line or
something like that so it's funny it's
like it's like or somebody says
something wrong within you all of a
sudden that to adapt something to change
it so the script is still like yes you
have to lock in the script to be able to
schedule everything to you know have
your you know your your production plans
and so forth but at the same time like
the scripts really not locked until
post-production
you